on le disait haïti à peine à se relever
la population accuse ses dirigeants de
corruption la pauvreté extrême
le manque de logement lui et chroniques
les infrastructures sont déficients tout
ça ça rend le pays bien vulnérable en
cas d'autres catastrophes naturelles
d'autres tremblements de terre on
parlait de notre envoyé spécial en haïti
sophie langlois il a eu l'occasion de
s'entretenir avec le président joël
moïse qui lui dit garder espoir de
sortir son pays de la crise
je venais le moïse dont les appels à la
démission se multiplient dans la rue le
mentionne haïti je dois vous dire propos
premièrement c'est une nation qui ne va
pas mourir et haïti ne ne ne peut pas
mourir et on est claire là dessus c'est
pas seulement de parler de l'espoir mais
il faut agir aussi et pour agir moi je
le dis après m'être 211 mois
d'expérience il faut oser agir et c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de faire
aujourd'hui pour dire à nos compatriotes
qu'ils sont
dans l'étrange et ceux qui vivent au
canada et aux états unis on parle de
plus plusieurs millions d'haïtiens
aujourd'hui nous devons nous mettre
ensemble pour mettre haïti sur les rails
du pauvre mais pour ce faire il faut il
faut en fait des réformes en profondeur
et ces réformes peuvent se faire
première manche inchangé
cette constitution voilà aujourd'hui le
message que j'ai pour mes frères mes
soeurs et frères de la diaspora
ils doivent comprendre aujourd'hui que
nous sommes à un carrefour où cette
crise permanent qui n'a jamais cessé
dans le pays de mettre le pays dans une
instabilité chronique
nous sommes arrivés à un caveau que le
problème et y est identifié ce problème
qui est identifié quel est ce problème
c'est un problème ou le mois l'égoïsme
hockey qui veut prendre place au quai et
à des choses collectives
maintenant il faut que nous pensions à
changer d'attitude et c'est pour ça moi
même arrivé à la tête de l'état
j'ai dit que je suis en train de libérer
l'état parce que l'état à captieux les
teintes absolue est passé à theolia
qu'on pût l'étain kaptué par jeudi est
une sorte de danse hommes de lois
traditionnelles et c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que moi même je prends ma
responsabilité de dire nous devons
libérer l'état et pour ce faire nous
avons besoin de tout le monde
des haïtiens qui sont ce qu'ils sont à
l'étranger des haïtiens venus d'ici et
d'ailleurs
nos amis de l'international parce que
c'est encore flou décisif pour nous pour
transformer cette crise là et en une
opportunité pour sortir ici aux clés de
cette instabilité politique chronique
qui nous cadres en fait dans un
sous-développement jeu
je dirais presque endémique mais en fait
je pense que nous allons pouvoir sentir
si nous nous mettons ensemble